we wouldn't want to put you on the spot
but we do have a guitar here I don't
know about I don't know but it is how
well I audience would want but they got
and they got I think that I'm David
Brent otherwise it's weird
let me get your character there you go
dee bag I do in it I'll get some water
so yeah yeah yeah grab you one right
there when I walked in a was yeah the
whole time yeah I mean this has all been
one big toy we've been building to this
the entire time
yeah yeah it's all about context no I'm
just singing a song yeah it's like a pie
when I blow get the guitar what we're
going okay so anyway off yeah we're
going to sell them to the sounds of
Ricky oh my god
anybody listening just like I heard that
Ricky Gervais guy supposed to be funny
but this is always yeah the stuff about
compassion and then he started singing
oh here we go
is it um we're gonna plug it in I'm not
a real doctor
what's my thing
I mean might get my favorite song at the
moment is probably the disabled song I
don't know I think I think that only
works yeah I mean yeah yeah um so how
that's a nice gray so it's okay I do
that and the fact that you see equi
distant restore me at first
oh my god or not I don't think a lot of
these in yeah we get water
oh I'll do it oh sorry I didn't realize
way down there still funny still funny
that 155 why darkness why do I love
pitchy okay
all this is in baoshan isn't it
I remember okay besides we're starting
yeah right now
[Music]
more convenient Danna Tesco Express
coastal Windsor but the property's less
it keeps the businesses of Britain great
it's got your biggest trading stage it
doesn't matter where you're from you
wanna work then come along the station's
just got a new floor and the motorway
runs by your door and you know just
where you're heading
it's like with this dumb tween London
and reading Wahoo's like my kind of town
I don't know how anyone could put you
down whoa Wow
my kind of town I don't know how anyone
could put you down to the west you've
got techno and Bray you got hailing them
the other way it's a brilliant place to
live and work it was in Bucks now
officially its birth don't believe what
the critics say like it's so lease and
boring and gray see for yourself what
you waiting for
we're on the path wrote that be a fall
and you know just where you're heading
it's like what this gun tween London and
read in Wahoo's la my kind of town I
don't know how anyone could put you down
whoa full-on
my kind of town I don't know how anyone
could put you down slow down
Wow
run
whoa-ho just the idea they're all like a
drama just the idea that like a guy like
David Brent would think that's a cool
idea to do if I need to spin about no
irony no to knowing about this local
town that knows no place in the field
with a zoo city says everything in this
song is factually accurate you might
learn something
oh yeah because we all want to know
about you and the stations has got a new
floor yeah what is the offensiveness now
you know close to winter but the
property's less that's not a good thing
is it if you say late sound the property
right